[موسيقى]
تشهد المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه غزه محيط
مستشفى الشفاء موجه من نزوح الناس بعد
تقدم الاليات في عده محاور من المناطق
الجنوبيه الغربيه لمدينه
غزه كما نلحظ ونرى بعض
الناس ينزحون من منطقه الشفاء خوفا وهروبا
من الخطر الشديد المحيط بهم والمحلق بهم
الى المناطق الشرقيه من مدينه غزه حشوا
علينا اليهود من باب الشفا بعدين ظلهم
يقربوا لما وصلوا باب المدرسه باب المدرسه
الرمال في غزه وطب علينا قدايه وطيارات من
فوقنا ورصاص واش كمان وعندها تسع شهداء
وعنا اصابات وشرنا بالخوف وبرع ما عرفناش
كيف شردنا جينا من الرم له هنا مشي من
الخوف مرعوبين جينا وهي بنتي مصوبه بنتي
مصوبه اليهود كانت بالمره ولا بترحم طفل
ولا بترحم صغير ولا بترحم اي حاجه
الدبابات وقفين على باب المدرسه وتحصر بعد
ساعه ما طلعنا في
العتمه في العتمه صرنا نمشي ونقع فوق
بعضنا واحنا شاردين في العتمه في شهدا
خبطنا على تحتيهم وظلينا
عدين من الخوف تحت جرينا الشه
واحد